Mr zahawi have you been honest about
your tax Affairs Mr zahawi at the center
of a storm but today still very welcome
at the heart of government have you been
honest about your tax Affairs Mr zahari
Tory party chairman Nadine zahawi has
been at the top table of cabinet for
years Boris Johnson's final Chancellor
he ran to become Prime Minister Last
Summer
but it's alleged that Mr zahari saved
millions of pounds in tax by putting
shares in a trust in Gibraltar
categorically denied to Sky News during
his leadership bid I was not the
beneficiary of the balshaw investment
that held those shares
um and who was my family is it's the
potential public record
um uh my my father but why would you do
that if it wasn't for the purpose of
avoiding time because he's he lives
abroad he doesn't live in the United
Kingdom on Sunday came the report that
he had in fact paid several million
pounds to hmrc to settle the dispute
today that he'd also had to pay a fine
as part of the agreement in the face of
these allegations a spokesman today
would only say that his taxes are up to
date and fully paid in the UK
report that Nadim zahawi has paid a
seven figure sum and a fine in order to
settle his affairs with hm revenue and
Customs based in the building behind me
are not now explicitly denied by Mr
zahawi and his team
this is a man who wanted to become Prime
Minister and did become Chancellor
overseeing the nation's finances and the
operations of the taxman now it's an
issue for Rishi sunak who entered
Downing Street promising to return
professionalism integrity and
accountability to the government
labor say he should
gohari is not being clear either to hmrc
or to the British public then he has no
place in government this was Rishi
sinak's first cabinet meeting one
Minister has quit over their treatment
of officials the Deputy Prime Minister
still under investigation for Behavior
at work now the tax Affairs of a third
under scrutiny all in barely three
months in the job samcoat Sky News